remarque préalable comme monsieur le
secrétaire général de l'elysée monsieur
le directeur de cabinet vous avez fait
état de l'autorisation qui vous a été
donné par le président de la république
je veux dire ici que cette autorisation
n'a pas d'objet il n'a pas d'effets en
vertu du texte que chacun commence à
connaître
nous avons eu l'occasion d'en parler
beaucoup hier de l'article 6 de
l'ordonance du 17 novembre 1958 monsieur
sous brevet que vous connaissez
parfaitement mais qui peut voir que
toute personne tout citoyen qui est
convoqué par une commission d' enquête
parlementaire doit déférer à la
convocation
c'est tout nul n'est au dessus des lois
à cet égard nous veut devons le dire
avec beaucoup de force
tout citoyen tout citoyenne doit venir
pourquoi parce que le parlement fait la
loi et contrôler l'exercice des pouvoirs
publics
et dans ce cadre comme l'a dit le
président philippe bas vous contribuez à
notre mission